hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk a little bit more about
the gravedigger theory
just because Ian McShane has been doing
interviews and people are reporting that
he's giving away things about the plot I
don't necessarily think that's true but
I do think he's offering some hints just
in case you haven't heard
Ian McShane was cast in a very minor
role for a one-off episode and Game of
Thrones season 6 the reason people are
really excited is because when they
asked him what are you doing during Game
of Thrones Season six he's like well I
can't say much about it all I can say is
that I'm gonna show up once very briefly
and then you're probably never gonna see
me again
so that's why a lot of people are
thinking that it's somewhat of a
confirmation for the elder brother in
the gravedigger theory now because
that's a theory that depends on book
stuff even though the show's already
past that I'll just go ahead and say
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show and
everything that the show has skipped
from the books and also I should say a
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so why is the elder brother character
important and why would they cast
someone like Ian McShane someone as big
as him to do the part
well the elder brother serves with an
order of monks that just takes care of
people on the quiet Isle it's just a
small community in service to the 7and
and it's in the salt pans here if you
remember that's near the region where
Aria was last seen with the Hound at the
end of season 4 before Aria took off to
go to Braavos so during a feast for
crows book for Brienne is also looking
for missing Starks but she just goes in
a slightly different direction like on
the show she went all the way up to
Winterfell and camped out because she
knew Sansa was there in the books
everybody is in slightly different
location so brie ends in a slightly
different location - as she's traveling
through the Riverland she winds up at
the quiet Isle inquiring about missing
Starks but she notices that there's a
horse that used to belong to the Hound
the elder brother gives her some
information about the Hound still
implying that the Hound doesn't exist
anymore but there's this mysterious
gravedigger character who's about the
Hound size walks with an injury that
seems similar to an injury that the
Hound sustained so a lot of people
myself included think that the Hound is
still alive especially when you look at
what happened during season 5 when when
Arya was becoming a faceless person when
she was playing The Lying game with
jaqen she almost let slip that she still
missed the Hound like she still cared
about him even though she said that she
did not
meaning that there might be some
unfinished business between the two of
them and I definitely think that Ari has
headed back to Westeros at a certain
point so I think at some point if not
next seasons and the season after maybe
even season eight that Aria will meet
the Hound again seriously there is so
much unfinished business between
characters on Game of Thrones I hope
they don't have to dump any storylines
because after season six they should
have at least 20 more episodes that'd be
like the subtitle of their movie if they
had to do a movie to wrap everything up
after the series ended its run Game of
Thrones unfinished business all the
storylines that we had to drop
Ian McShane though there are a lot of
possibilities for who his character
could be but but I think that the elder
brother is the best pick there are a lot
of people that thought he might be
Septon Mayer ball because that's another
character that gets tied up with the
quiet Isle the elder brother and the
gravedigger but that would require even
more screen time the elder brothers
there's a really important part in the
story and it's very brief so I feel like
it fits his description of like a
character that you're only gonna see a
little bit of and then never again
but you guys let me know in the comments
who do you think Ian McShane scare
icterus do you think he's the older
brother do you think he's Septon marry
bald do you think he's somebody
completely different and I know a lot of
you guys have been asking about telltale
Game of Thrones they're releasing the
final chapter on Tuesday so I'm gonna
play the trailer here this is the
trailer for the finale
loyalty can be such a hard thing to
define you are a girl from the north
here in service to lady Marjorie if your
loyalties were to become conflicted
between your king and the very person
who you serve what would you do then
I would be true to they came your grace
Duncan roiland this house needs you both
but you can only choose one my lord
Duncan total you will be my Sentinel
total this is reckless
you want to kill me don't you prove how
strong you are
do it for eatin
your little brother had bigger balls
than you now that bow humility steady
runs off me you can aware me
what rich enough that's enough trick the
gate will fall without one of us holding
it one of us has to stay
let me save your life on our house iron
from ice from iron from ice
I'll hold them off Roderick go
next time on Game of Thrones
it's
Gregor then freon
orna sagar van
the game itself has been pretty fun but
I actually I lost all my game save data
it really sucked I upgraded to a new
computer but it ended up trashing my
game safe so I got a like marathon the
first five episodes of the game to play
this last one if I can get it done in
time I'll totally do gameplay videos on
my game channel if you don't know where
that is there's a link in the
description it's just called Charlie
streams but if you haven't bought the
game itself yet it's only about 25 bucks
for all six episodes it's pretty fun and
the actors from the show actually do
their voices for their game characters
most of the questions I see about it
though are like you know whether or not
game stuff has influence on what's going
on in the TV show or in the books it's
loosely related like it's based on stuff
in the books and stuff on the show but
I'm not expecting the show or the books
to ever reference what's going on in the
game it's kind of like its own separate
universe but I'll say congratulations to
last week's giveaway winner
Abigail Greene you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact info we did start getting
some teasers for Game of Thrones Season
5 at the end of November last year so we
might see some viral trailers in the
next couple of weeks if we do I'll
totally do videos for it so don't worry
if you see me freaking out about Game of
Thrones trailers you'll know that
they're here well you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn all about White Walkers during
season six and you can click here to
learn all about the Captain America's
Civil War post credits scene during
ant-man thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you